we just sort of remember him as a father
as a loving father as a loving
grandfather he was a lovely man he would
have done anything for you
we can't go back i understand that but
we need to learn some serious lessons
from this so this doesn't happen again
back in january 2020 83 year old peter
atwood passed away
long before covert became a national
dilemma and when the concern was limited
mostly to china the kovi did only just
sort of like come about in china so
we were told you know without a shadow
of doubt it was not in this country at
the time so there was no way
it was on our radar at the time the the
tipping point for me i think was the
the inability to get off the oxygen he
struggled so much
and as time went by and we knew more and
more about covering we saw these
patients in hospital
with the not been able to breathe that i
just kept thinking
this isn't right public health experts
claim peter edwards case lays bare the
uk's failure to monitor the virus in its
early stages
and that there may have been many more
deaths in the early months of 2020 than
was first thought
the first covert death in the uk was
recorded on the 5th of march of 2020
weeks before the government succumbed to
lockdown on the 23rd of march
by that time the pandemic had already
sunk its teeth into the country
but jane's father passed on the 30th of
january of 2020
and that was only days after the city of
wuhan where the first case of covett
were detected
went into lockdown she's now calling for
the world's health organization
and the nhs to publicly recognize the
historical significance of her father's
passing
as the uk's first covert fatality
i just feel that he should go down in
history you know it is a part of history
now isn't
it you know it doesn't matter what you
read in the books you know there's
always that
that date of that first person and i
think my dad should really have that
remembered while 2020 the year of covet
will go down in history as being totally
unknown
and unprecedented jane says it's not
just about her father's legacy but about
correcting the official records
but the government says there was little
transmission present at the time of
peter atwood's death
every death is a tragedy there is no
evidence that there was sustained
transmission within the community in
january 2020.
we acted swiftly to curb coronavirus and
at all times we have been guided by the
best available
evidence to deliver a strategy designed
to protect the nhs
and save lives for jane though questions
still remain unanswered about what
actually happened and if anything would
have been different had the government
acted sooner to alert the country